you may not realize it but we're in the
middle of a high stakes War not in the
Middle East but right here in your
browser and what's at stake is a few
precious seconds of your attention while
staring at this magic glowing screen it
is November 24th 2023 and you're
watching the code report back in June
2023 a small group of YouTube users were
surprised to get this message cutting
them off for having an ad blocker
enabled making them the first casualties
of YouTube's ad blocker blocker because
you're just a material girl living in a
material world your attention is very
valuable it only takes a few seconds for
a good advertisement to inject some
information into your hippo campus where
it can then be transferred to the
frontal lobe to manipulate your impulse
control to get you to buy something you
don't need by the way guys Black Friday
Cyber Monday sale buers ship Pro 40% off
learn to code and get a free t-shirt buy
it now before the impulse Fades from
your prefrontal cortex that's an example
of an honest advertisement that you
should definitely take advantage of but
most companies need to pay someone else
to shill for them in 2022 alphabet The
company generated $280 billion in
Revenue that's a lot of money but 224
billion of that is from from
advertisements but then what's even more
crazy is that of that 224 only 29
billion comes from YouTube That's only
11% of advertising revenue and I would
have expected that number to be a lot
higher based on the number of ads that I
skip on YouTube it's the second most
popular website in the world but
platforms like Facebook and Instagram do
a much better job of generating ad
revenue on top of that YouTube is
extremely expensive to operate streaming
a video around the world with low
latency requires massive data centers
with CDN all over the world YouTube's
infrastructure is truly a technological
Marvel and they offer for it all for
free in exchange for a little bit of
your privacy and some real estate in
your brain however this is unacceptable
for many because it requires an invasion
of privacy information might be
collected about your browsing history
location and demographics just to show
you targeted advertisements and that's
kind of creepy that's the philosophical
argument anyway but mostly ads are just
annoying as and we should have the
freedom to use the internet the way we
want to although as a content creator
myself I could make the argument that ad
block is theft whenever you watch an ad
55% goes to me with the other 45% going
to the big guy however when someone goes
to the Chrome web store and installs
ublock origin an open source Chrome
plugin used by 34 million other people
it uses a variety of techniques to block
ads both on websites and YouTube like
it'll block Network requests that go to
ad servers it'll block analytics tools
that collect data and also blocks the
JavaScript that's responsible for
displaying things like banner ads once
installed you can test it to make sure
that it's working okay on websites like
ad block tester.com and because it's all
open source you can see how everything
works in the source code here on GitHub
but now you're a filthy p pirate
stealing from honest creators like Logan
PA and SS sniperwolf and if you keep
installing things like ad block ad block
plus adguard ghosty ublock origin ad
blocker ultimate or use privacy focused
browsers like Brave YouTube's going to
go out of business and take all of its
creators with it that's the argument
anyway and YouTube has been cracking
down recently it's been promoting its
own ad blocker YouTube premium and it
shares revenue from that product with
YouTube creators in full disclosure I've
been an affiliate for YouTube premium in
a past video and I currently use it
myself but there's a significant number
of people out there who you couldn't pay
to pay for the service no matter how
much advertising you tried to inject
into their incons Facebook also waged
war against ad blockers back in 2016 but
largely failed although Netflix recently
cracked down on account sharing which to
them is considered theft and their
stalks have been way up ever since and
the thing is YouTube could just ignore
this issue and chalk it up to the cost
of doing business on the internet but
instead they woke up and chose violence
if you have an ad blocker enabled you
may get this warning that video playback
will be disabled if you don't disable
your ad blocker in addition the overall
experience for ad block user users will
likely get worse in the future like
recently a small group of users were
noticing a 5-second delay before a video
started playing which is apparently part
of YouTube's efforts to detect ad
blockers now a bigger part of this war
though comes down to Chrome extensions
when you build a Chrome extension you
have to have a manifest.json file this
file defines what the extension is
allowed to do on the user's behalf like
Access Network requests to block ads if
we look at the Manifest for you block
you'll first notice that it's using
manifest version two then if we go down
to permissions you'll notice it's using
web request and web request blocking
these apis made it easy for an extension
to intercept a network request and then
modify it so it can't display the ad it
wants to now the thing is Manifest
version 2 is being deprecated in favor
of version 3 which replaces the web
request API with the declarative net
request API Which is far more limited
when it comes to dynamically filtering
content what's kind of funny is that
Chrome actually might need ad blockers
because as recently as last Christmas
the FBI was recommending people install
them to protect against malicious
advertisements hosting ransomware
ultimately I do think it's possible that
YouTube could eradicate ad blockers
altogether but currently it's a lot like
when Barbara strand tried to suppress a
photo of her house that almost nobody
knew about resulting in the opposite
intended effect making the photo
extremely famous we're currently seeing
the Strand effect with ad blockers where
more and more people are learning about
them and using them despite the fact
that they violate the terms of service
it's also making the ad blockers become
more sophisticated it's only a matter of
time before someone invents an ad
blocker blocker blocker that can block
this ad blocker blocker forcing YouTube
to then invent its own ad blocker
blocker block ER blocker at which point
this joke becomes too repetitive this
has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one